bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec nous
l'inde qui enregistre donc car
enregistraient dimanche 350 milles qu'un
en 24 heures c'est un chiffre c'est vrai
très impressionnant mais si on compare
aux 1,3 milliard d'habitants que compte
le pays c'est finalement peu oui tout à
fait bon ça reste des chiffres
inquiétants mais je j'entends dire que
comme mario et c'est à juste titre nous
préoccupe
il faut comprendre aussi que l'inde est
un pays densément peuplées c'est un pays
dans lequel elles et pour différentes
raisons notamment parce qu'ils avaient
des rassemblements religieux très
important ces dernières semaines des
rassemblements liés également à des
processus électoraux qui sont en cours
en inde
eh bien on en a on a favorisé on a créé
les conditions d'une circulation virale
très active alors peut-être qu'elle est
amplifié par les propriétés de ce
variant qui est encore à l'étude dont on
sait assez peu de choses mais très
clairement on a affaire à des situations
particulières qui ont favorisé la
circulation du virus globalement sur un
territoire qui étaient déjà exposées
depuis depuis un an
alors comment est ce qu'il faut faire
justement pour éviter que ce variant
indien ne se propage un peu partout avec
20 étudiants indiens ont été testés
positifs à ce variant alors arrivée à
bruxelles
après avoir justement transité par
roissy les contrôles aux frontières il
faut les renforcer
alors je dirais que le problème il est
pas spécifique aux variants indien
l'idée de toute façon de limiter
l'import sur le territoire national et
sur le territoire européen plus
généralement de variants qui auraient
des propriétés
d'échappement au vaccin par exemple ou
des propriétés de virulence ou de
contagiosité accrue donc les mesures que
l'on prend de toute façon sont des
mesures qui visent à limiter au maximum
l'introduction de ces nouvelles formes
il n'y a pas il n'y a pas 36 solutions
la seule façon de le faire c'est
effectivement lors de vols
particulièrement à risque de tester les
passagers et surtout de mettre en place
qui a toujours été un problème en france
des procédures d'isolement des
procédures de quarantaine d'environ 10
jours de manière à limiter la
circulation ces gens sur le territoire
tant qu'ils sont dans une période où
potentiellement ils peuvent contaminer
leur entourage
donc il est absolument essentiel mais
c'est vrai autant pour ce variant que
pour les autres de mettre en place des
procédures de contrôle aux frontières et
idéalement il faut avoir une
concertation européenne sur cette
question alors justement la restriction
des vols le gouvernement l'a annoncé
avec cet isolement obligatoire de 10
jours pour les vols venant d'inde mais
aussi votre pays le brésil le chili
l'argentine encore l'afrique du sud
est ce que ray véritablement c'est
suffisant alors suffisant ou le sait
toujours sur la durée ce qui est clair
c'est que de ne rien faire favorisera la
réintroduction répétées de variants qui
pose des problèmes
si on interdit si on contrôle en tout
cas les vols en provenance du brésil
c'est pas pour le vario indien en
l'occurrence c'est bien parce que au
brésil circulaire variant qu'on connaît
maintenant depuis quelques mois dont on
sait qu'il est problématique même de la
même façon le variant qui circulent en
afrique du sud est un variant
problématique parce qu'il semble que les
réponses immunitaires dirigée contre ces
virus soit moins importante soit moins
efficace donc en tout état de cause
c'est une mesure qu'il est important de
prendre aujourd'hui le temps que les
processus de vaccination se mettent en
place sur le territoire européen que les
populations soient mieux protégés il
faut effectivement pour le des mesures
ça en fait partie
bien sûr mais est-ce qu'il faut
véritablement s'inquiéter parce que vous
parlez des variants brésilien on sait
que le conseil scientifique a prévenu a
alerté face à une vague importante d'ici
l'été ça veut dire qu'après le variant
indien pourrait aussi provoquer le même
effet compenser on peut c'est très
difficile d'anticiper ce qui va se
passer
ce qu'on sait c'est qu'il faut d'abord
caractériser les propriétés de ces
variants on n'aura pas tout à fait la
même passion avec des variants qui vont
être bloqués par la réponse immunitaire
naturel ou vaccinale et des variants qui
pourraient échapper donc la question se
pose il ya un autre phénomène qui
intervient le variant sud africain
aujourd'hui aux alentours de 4 à 5 % des
cas détectés en moyenne mais
probablement aussi parce que le variant
britannique et variant 2001 aujourd'hui
empêche ce variante s'implanter sur le
territoire faut pas oublier qu'à une
compétition entre les virus et un
instant donné
encore une fois il faut à la fois limité
la circulation du virus est limité la
circulation du virus et mettre en place
des procédures de dépistage et
d'isolement efficace en attendant de
déployer de façon tout à fait efficace
une campagne de vaccination qui
protégera l'essentiel de la population à
risque j'aurais peut-être dû commencer
par là que c'est ton finalement de ce
variant indien il est plus transmissible
et ce qu'il est plus dangereux que le
variant britanniques ou aux brésiliens
c'est donc un c'est très beau c'est très
tôt pour le dire selon ce qu'on déduit
on le déduit des mutations qui ont été
détectés sur ce variant il ya deux
mutations qui sont un peu problématique
lune parce qu'on l'avait étudié et
identifié sur une forme qui avait sévi
en californie il ya quelques mois et
l'eau parce que c'est une des mutations
préoccupante du variant sud africain on
se retrouve par un phénomène qu'on
appelle une convergence évolutive avec
la présence de ces deux mutations un peu
problématique sur le sur le même virus
et de plex concept ces mutations dans
d'autres contextes et qu'elles limitent
la réponse immunitaire
donc ça c'est un facteur nous préoccupe
beaucoup et on sait également que
certaines de ces mutations sont associés
à elle contagieuse est plus importante
on ne sait pas aujourd'hui en revanche
c'est si ces variants sont plus
virulents et au globalement on se
conseille aussi de ces variants c'est
principalement ce qu'on déduit d'études
qui ont peut-être fait ailleurs on n'a
pas encore d'études poussées sur le
territoire indien qui permettra de
qualifier le potentiel de ce virus
mais on sait qu'il est déjà très présent
je crois qu'on estime dans certaines
études qu'il est déjà présent à plus de
30% dans les souches qui sont analysés
non mais c'est vrai que
la gestion de la crise sanitaire en inde
par exemple là on voit que les cas
explose on pouvait imaginer qu'il y
avait une immunité quand même importante
visiblement ce n'est pas le cas en inde
on peut là ça mais c'est toujours c'est
toujours très compliqué parce que
d'abord il ya une première vague mais
qui a été relativement bien contrôlé il
ya quasiment un an il y avait une
première vague d'épidémie que là que
l'inde pour différentes raisons avaient
réussi à voir régresser assez rapidement
le problème aujourd'hui de l'inde sait
qu'après cette première vague il ya une
confiance très importante probablement
des politiques et aussi des gens qu'il
faut que très vite l'inde à rome un
rythme de vie normal sans mesures
particulières de contrôle de l'infection
et puis des événements qu'on avait
évoqué des grands rassemblements pour
des élections des grands rassemblements
religieux ont facilité la circulation du
virus alors dans certains territoires en
inde notamment dans la région de new
delhi on imagine que près de 50% de la
population a été exposé au virus
maintenant la question qui se pose c'est
effectivement est ce que ces variants
sont capables de réaffecter des gens qui
auraient déjà rencontré le virus il ya
plusieurs mois aujourd'hui on n'a pas
les informations qui permettent de
l'affirmer comme on n'a pas non plus
d'informations qui permet de dire que le
variant est plus virulent ce qu'on sait
c'est qu'il ya une vague épidémique
majeur et plus le virus circule plus il
ya des cas et puis ya des cas
malheureusement
puis il ya des cas graves merci beaucoup
à vous vincent maréchal rappelle quand
vous êtes professeur de virologie à la
sorbonne universités